- On this episode i talk about mistakes,
forest, lunch, and keynotes.
(energetic music and audience applause)
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
(energetic music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and welcome to episode number 42 of the
#AskGaryVee Show.
No fun facts, just thunder.
- [Voiceover] Mathieu says,
"Hello Gary, why do you
"rarely mention YouTube in
your digital recommendations
"despite the one billion
active users per month?"
- And this is a great question and I'm
really glad you asked it because
it allows me to address this head-on
on the #AskGaryVee Show.
The reason I don't
mention YouTube a lot and
didn't have it at the bottom logo of
Jab Jab Jab Right Hook,
DRock, you can show it,
is a really interesting
thing that I've thought about
quite a bit.
Which is
because I'm making a mistake.
And, you know, boy, do
I hate talking about
that stuff.
You know, here's what I think happened.
I jumped on YouTube so early back in 2006,
wrote Crush It! in 2009
about how YouTube and video
would make a lot of people famous,
a lot of stuff that's happening now.
And in a weird way, I think that,
you know I jumped to Viddler in 2007
so I didn't see through the YouTube thing,
that was a mistake as well.
I think that it's a foregone conclusion
in the back of my mind that I have
YouTube on a pedestal that is even above
everything else, maybe besides Facebook,
and I just haven't done a good job.
As a matter of fact one of the reasons
I started the #AskGaryVee
Show is to get a little bit
back into the YouTube culture and so,
honestly, I think that the reason I don't
mention it and dig into it
and push it harder is
because I thought I'd
figured that out and
kind of pushed that out
with Crush It! and was
so associated with that.
But that wore out in 2011 and I've just
done a piss-poor job of
continuing that narrative
and it's a hole in my tool belt in the way
that I communicate.
Obviously I take it seriously, and so,
you know, the reason I don't mention it
is because I'm making a mistake.
- [Voiceover] Yash says,
"You changed the intro music.
"Why?"
- Yash, cuz.
- [Voiceover] Vernon
asks, "What's one question
"you ask in interviews?"
- Vernon, I really like this question.
I'm really excited to take a stab at it.
I don't do it every time.
I'm not one of these guys who's like,
this is my go-to question, like
"When you were 13 and you
went through a forest,
and you pick--"
I don't have any of these weird things,
but I do always, especially
I think if there's a lot
of momentum in the interview,
I love to ask people to tell me, at this
moment in time, what they see the
professional career becoming.
I wanna get into the psychology of what
their ambition is and I pretty much
spend most of the interview trying to get
somebody comfortable enough to tell me
the truth to that question.
Because I don't care if
you want to be the CEO
of VaynerMedia. If you wanna just be,
move a couple levels up and have great
work-life balance. I
don't care if you even
want to come here and
work for me for two years,
suck out my IP and then
go start your own agency.
I don't care what your agenda is, I just
wanna know what it is so
I can help us get there.
Because the truth is,
I wanna keep people in
my ecosystem forever and the best way
to do that is to deliver
to them what they want.
And so the quicker I can
get into that insight,
are you work-life balance,
are you money hungry,
are you title hungry, are you entrepreneur
and just coming in here for learnings.
I don't care, I just need to know.
The quicker I know and the
quicker it's the truth,
the quicker we can do
things forever together.
And so that is usually the essence of the
interview question for me.
Can I tap through, can I
feel that I'm getting there?
Because that gives me a blueprint, a map.
Not only that, I have the
self-awareness, and I try to
talk to them about this,
that that will change.
You know, being a 24 year old dude,
26 year old female, it's gonna change.
You're gonna fall in love,
your life's gonna change.
Are you gonna start a family?
When you make a little bit more money
it becomes less interesting.
There's so many different
things that are going
on in one's life.
When you make a little money it becomes
way more interesting.
You get the bug, the blood's in the water.
I don't care, I just need
the communication funnel
and I want it to start from day one,
five minutes in to getting
to know each other.
- [Voiceover] Sarah asks,
"As a private music teacher
"I have limited hours to teach.
"What are your thoughts on
how to increase my income,
"or build a brand?"
- Sarah, a lot of thoughts on this.
It's called the Crush It! manifesto,
which is, there's plenty of damage between
11pm and three in the morning.
I get it, you teach,
you know, I don't know,
teachers to me are actually,
my sister is a teacher,
like they have the most
time to do other stuff.
They have fairly good schedules.
There's the summer.
There's, you know, and
again, maybe you've got
a different kind of teaching thing, but
to me, if you want to build
more of a scalable brand,
you gotta put out content. You gotta
look at things like Skillshare where you
can put out your teachings and sell that.
There's a lot of ways to do it.
Technology has created
an enormous opportunity
for you to scale it.
You can do live Spreecasts
and Google Hangouts
that only have access to people that pay.
I would recommend putting
out a lot of content
at first as a gateway
drug to the opportunity
to charge people so you
can establish yourself.
But this whole notion of
where is the time, I need more time,
I just think people are
loaded with excuses.
They aren't auditing themselves.
They don't realize that
they're watching every season
of Homeland and Game of Thrones.
They don't realize that
they're having an hour
and 15 minute lunch, like lunch.
I've had two lunches.
Robert Souza, our new SVP made me go to
a lunch to meet somebody.
I was pissed.
I was like, why couldn't
we do that as 11pm drinks?
Lunch, like leaving and having lunch?
The inefficiency of that time?
So you know, I'm pissed at lunch
and I'm pissed at Game of Thrones and
I'm pissed at playing video games and
I'm pissed at a lot of
things in a world where
somebody wants more
financially or career-wise.
I love it for the people
that need it to escape.
I love it for people that are content
with their monies and their career path.
I love it.
As a matter of fact, I envy it.
Boy, if somebody could take a shot and
suck out some of my ambition,
I'd be really pumped.
You wanna do a start up?
Create a suck out the ambition app.
I'd be really happy about
that because I'd love
to be able to take a lunch.
I'd love to be able to relax
and play Madden against
somebody in Iowa, because
that's how you can
play Madden these days, with the kids,
for the last 10 years.
But I haven't been playing it because
I've been hustling,
because that's what I want.
And so, whether you're a hundred or zero,
you just wanna zen and live in
a mountain with no technology
or you wanna buy the Jets
and hustle your face off,
or anything in between, you
need to find your cadence.
And so if you're asking this question,
my intuition is you're
spending an hour or two
on things every day that aren't achieving
this extra brand or extra
monies that you're chasing.
So cut that crap out and
apply it to these things,
putting out content, writing content,
making videos, building up a brand,
engaging with people,
going to Twitter search,
Twitter.com/search
searching teachings around, you know,
key words around the things you teach.
Engage with people, say hello, cold call,
saw somebody shout that out
in the YouTube comments yesterday.
We talked about that, as a matter of fact,
link up that video.
People need to watch it.
That's a classic.
I don't know where you want it, DRock.
But you guys know which
video I'm talking about.
The cold call. I had a
shaved head in there.
Anyway, the bottom line is, you need to
re-calibrate to your ambitions.
By the way, it may be going
from seven hours of sleep
to five hours of sleep
because you need all those
lunches and video games, and that's fine.
But if you want it, you just gotta go
and do that.
Thank you so much for watching
episode 42 of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Felt good about--
had an interesting demeanor.
Had an interesting demea--
Yeah, right DRock?
DRock, he's got my
demeanor of meter down, so
can I get a demeter
meter, like, can we get
a demeanor meter info-graphic here?
Thanks for watching the show.
I'm really enjoying it and
I'm really feeling the impact.
I'm starting to get
emails already from people
that have done certain things through
episode 16, 19, 23, how
about episode 23 by the way?
(ding)
I just did that for no reason,
(mumbles) when we go back.
I appreciate that, I love that interaction
and you keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
There's a video question, right?
Let's do the video question.
Jab Jab Jab Right Hook
is actually what I do.
Give, give, give and then ask.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
And welcome to #AskGaryVee.
Do you consider yourself
in the VaynerNation?
Or do you consider yourself a Vayniac?
(typewriter keys clicking)
- Ishmael, somebody is very smart.
You've got me pegged.
Absolutely, I'm excited about
building the brand equity
of the #AskGaryVee Show so I can
have my ambition, and
you've probably heard me
say this five to 10
times in my career so you
might have a leg up from anybody
else who hasn't heard this.
Nothing would excite me more,
look, I've contemplated
television and other things
to build up my profile so
that my keynotes going forward
can be me walking into
a auditorium, an event,
and just going directly into
Q and A, #AskGaryVee style,
because the truth is, that's where you can
bring the most value.
If people walk in with context of who I am
and my spiel, we can get right to it,
which is really bringing the value,
which is why this show matters so much.
So yes, my friend, the
answer to your question
is a big, fat Y-E-S.
I'd like the #AskGaryVee Show concept to be
my new keynote.
(beep)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching
(beep)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're (laughing)
(beep)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and (laughing)
You like that?
Oh crap, wait.
Subscribe.
(simulates fast-paced popping)
I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right hooks
in social, so subscribe.
(sirens)